welcome back to new rockstars we're
celebrating a batman friday as a new
franchise of the world's greatest
detective begins we've all seen the film
so this is going to be spoiler city for
real i'm about to be the mayor of
spoiler city so if you haven't seen the
batman yet save this video for later but
if you're all caught up inflate your
glide suit and dive on in with us this
is rogue theory the show where we pitch
the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we love my name is mt and
going rogue with me today is the
internet's greatest detective that's a
fact it's jessica clements what's going
on juice hey they usually call me
jeffrey wright but i'm okay with jessica
today just rewrite just rewrite yes
rewrite and someone who's always been
kind to strays it's whitney van
laningham what's going on whitney ah i'm
pug woman like catwoman but i eat snacks
only i only steal food that's my thing
oh my god we need to put a woman in the
d.c
and manager of his own club inside the
club it's off-screen producer zack
what's going on zac i'm so excited to be
here i'm i'm happy to be here i'm
honored to be here and i'm vengeance
when i left the theater last night i had
a giant flannel and i kept making into
batwings i'm a child and i kept going i
am the night i am vengeance avenge me
avenge me alfred like i kept being so
weird and people were like jessica calm
down i was like i'm so hyped on this
that's the type of stuff i do so i
appreciate that a lot but hey now that
we've all seen matt reeve's vision for
gotham city presented on the big screen
in fabulous fashion he beat up a lot of
people we can't help but wonder what
other stories could be told so that
leads us to our first topic of today
what's next for the batman because now
that the first film is out of the way
it's time to start speculating about the
sequel because director matt reeves
confirmed at the london premiere for the
batman that a sequel is definitely in
the works because why wouldn't it be by
god this movie is so amazing and
additionally a confirmed spin-off series
centering around the penguin is headed
to hbo max and with a new villain for
gotham being teased at the end of the
film
what's next for this version of the
batman take it away
anybody
not everybody else not everybody all at
once not everybody all that works please
let me know hey i'm you guys we normally
i'll kick it off here i i do think like
the the the movie purposely ends with
like all of the bad guys with the
exception of a couple mobsters alive and
well right in an asylum we know is
probably very easy to break out of right
that's the like the core of the batman
rogues gallery ethos right is that we're
gonna see these guys again knowing that
we're probably gonna get two hbo max
series before we get another film right
that we'll we're probably going to
explore like the full mob arc through
both the penguin series and the gotham
pd series and i kind of as that arc is
done maybe penguin is is locked up he's
kind of done with right then for the
next film
boom somebody's breaking out of arkham
maybe with the help of the riddler we're
getting joking maybe
you normally can't keep joker away from
us for that long
is it joker or druid i mean i don't know
i mean maybe it's a little bit yeah it's
just what if it's a weird villain
this is the batman they chose they chose
the joker to be the crossover for the
marvel universe
i mean the way that the batman ended
we're definitely going to be seeing
joker very soon i'm very excited to see
a joker in this universe but yeah like i
can definitely see joker um and the
penguin just having a conversation in
prison before maybe all three of them
break out together it's like hey the
crime seems great penguin thanks for
telling me all those stories from your
hbo max series let's go
i'm not
i'm not tired i love batman
any harley quinn thing is my jam uh it's
completely dc harlequin is my number one
but i i'm like we have so much joker
stuff in the world that i was really
banking on not seeing joker again but i
think what i want to see from this joker
is this joker being a weak joker and i
know like with this timeline we're
seeing a younger version of like
everything like the original like how
they originated everything but i want
this joker to get beat up all the time i
don't want this joker like how the
riddler had like a small like a small
following of people that came and shot
up the the dome or whatever you want to
call it at the end i want like the joker
to have less than that i want the joker
to be so insane when he escapes from
arkham that it's just like he constantly
gets his ass kicked i want the penguin
to be stronger than this joker like i i
hope matt reeves gives us like such a
weak bitch-ass joker because every time
we see the joker now it's just like he's
unstoppable he's the number one villain
which is true but like we just saw the
penguin and he was pretty
good so i want him to be more
established than the joker is and then
when joker gets older he'll be the
number one but for right now he's like
number five
he's number five okay i really want to
see a joker that's just like moderately
annoying and like that's it like he just
he pulls like like really really dumb
pranks and then he spends 10 minutes
laughing at his own joke and everyone
else is like dude that wasn't it dude
this guy sucks and funny yeah like this
guy's lame as hell dude why do you keep
bringing him
why
with stupid jokes yeah that's what i
want i want a joker who do you think
it's an interesting president in that
like the joker maybe in this universe
the riddler was a straight-up serial
killer right like the riddler was john
doe from seven he is just yeah he was
he was
maniacal yeah and he's literally just
murdering people no like hey solve this
riddle and you can save this guy like no
it's just like he's already dead here's
a riddle
yeah
something i thought was really
interesting too about this this one is
that batman never had a chance to like
actually save anyone like the this
riddler didn't even give him the option
to get there in time he didn't even
solve the alfred clue until he was
already exploded so i just yeah i
thought that that was like a really cool
diabolical choice to make that character
oh yeah the riddler won right he's my
favorite riddler but also my least
favorite riddler it's really weird like
he's so good and it was i love i love an
actual chaotic
and mind freak criss angel [ __ ]
and i'm looking for the joker played by
paul daniel
no but like i want my villains to be
merciless and this guy was straight up
hardcore he was like i'm doing this for
us
and he's like who's us he was like for
me and you baby i'm killing in your name
let's go
but like i also i hated how because i
love how kooky the joke or the riddler
is i love how stupid and silly is like
hello
and all his typewriters
so but then i was like i realized that
this is obviously a different version
this kind of pretends what the next
movie will be too right this movie
purposefully paralleled riddler and
batman so heavily right even both
characters would like watch people
through windows and like binoculars yeah
right like oh god
they kind of look the same right like
when um especially when batman's not in
his bad outfit when he's kind of in his
motorcycle gear he's dressed in the same
kind of uh
raincoat and whatever as the riddler
they're both orphans you know the same
age same background they're both
obsessive weirdos
right like who think they're doing good
and they're both trying to out
corruption like the riddler is just a
more twisted murderous version clearly
like the only difference between them is
like batman makes an appointed effort
not to kill people that's kind of it
right did you guys notice that the
riddler like is not following any coven
guidelines whatsoever because just his
nose was fully hanging out of that mask
everything else was covered except for
the goddamn sneeze zone put your mask
over your nose dude you can't just walk
around with your schnauze hanging out
like that victims he said kovan doesn't
even exist in this universe that's great
the one thing that i caught onto that i
also really like that the riddler did
which i don't know matt reeves meant to
do this but all the cards were like a
reflection of different dc villains for
batman and yeah that was a really cool
thing i was like oh that's the dr psycho
oh this is definitely harley this is
definitely ivy before she actually
turned into poison ivy going back to the
original actual thing what's an ex for
batman i basically agree with zach in
those regards that we have to see what's
gonna happen with the penguin series and
then it will lead to like how marvel
does it like their series are canon for
the movies uh this will be canon for the
movie so whatever happens in the penguin
will probably
be ten
gently i think this word whatever
connected to the movies and they will
break out of arkham and i think there
will be more than just the joker i think
we'll see more villains that get put in
arkham in the penguin series that will
also escape from arkham in the movie the
next movie with robert what's one
villain that you want to see with uh
joker and the riddler one that i don't
really i really want to see work where
at play is the calendar man i just
genuinely do
that's the way i genuinely just want to
see what he would do in this kind of
universe because he seems already
enough calendar man would be amazing
people don't understand like that would
actually be very good that's what i'm
thinking that's why i'm like this one
would be
murderous this one would be like really
ruthless because he's kind of like we
don't really care but i feel like in
this dark scenario he'd probably be
murdering a lot of people so i oh my god
matt reads calendar man don't sleep on
that people don't sleep on it and you
can do it it's easy enough he's easy
enough to do like you got he can do it
my reeves can do it with whitney did you
tell us what's next for batman from you
diet i'm just talking a lot in general
i'm sorry
i agree with uh with zach and jess i
hope that's not a boring answer these
are interesting people so how could that
be a boring answer yo freaking they're
geniuses geniuses they are gash dang
geniuses um i agree and honestly i would
love if the penguin series and then uh
the gotham pd series i just want it to
be like a mashup of the sopranos and law
and orders
but with batman characters
[Music]
oh maybe maybe maybe we will finally get
another type of flood in the dc universe
as long as it's robert pattinson that's
the only reason i'd care to see it
that's the only uh stipulation i have
and it has to be or
uh um michael keaton if it was michael
keane i'd watch it
[Laughter]
but yeah no i really like this idea of
you know obviously the joker coming
because like this is what they're
setting out but for the future i'm
really excited to see this actor's
portrayal of the joker because he's
fantastic um but like i really like this
idea of like a weak joker um being
presented into this new universe because
i feel like matt reeves strength as we
see in this movie is just these really
cerebral type villains that are more so
just like i'm i'm in your head more so
than like i can fight you and all that
stuff so like i think that you know
having a joker who just gets beat up a
lot and then like as these big big tough
guys like you know like become stronger
like your penguins and all this stuff
gets stronger and then we see joker
slowly rise as this guy who gets beat up
i love that idea i just think it's just
like we see the rise of the penguin and
the joker slowly i'm gonna give jess uh
10 million rogue points for that one and
um actually i would give everybody 10
million to the real quest for that one
no you already sent me you want to tell
me no okay
you do this every time i do this every
time i do this literally every time
because i feel bad for okay okay you
know what okay jessie's gonna get 20
million
it is
it is true okay i'm gonna give just 20
million and then you guys could get a 15
billion how's that
but i definitely am competitive turned
into uh uh we're really flooding the
market to uh we are
don't understand i need to feed my kids
with these points
exactly i gotta stop being so uh i don't
i was gonna say communist with my points
but maybe not say that um
okay it's fine um anyway this was all
amazing discussion i'm really looking
forward to seeing what matt reeves cooks
up for the batman sequel because i need
it tomorrow like what the heck are we
doing um but up next we're gonna talk
about some of these awesome bat gadgets
in the movie because my god they were
freaking dope but first our merch
partners at the epic hero shop have
released a series of extremely cool
limited edition t-shirts timed around
different properties called the latest
obsession series zach's got one on right
now the newest latest obsession shirt is
out right now and of course it's
inspired by the batman it's called
gotham noir it has a really cool design
inspired by the world's greatest
detective and his bath sleuthing and
they've got sizes from small all the way
up to 4x but it only comes in black and
any other cool color would be
disrespectful for the batman and hey
going online without expressvpn is like
changing while leaving your window wide
open you might not have anything to hide
but why give random creeps a chance to
invade your privacy when you go online
without a vpn isps can see every single
website that you visit very creepy not a
fan they can legally sell this
information to ad companies and tech
giants who then use your data to target
you this is a big reason why you should
be using vpns no matter what you're
surfing when you use expressvpn isps
cannot see your online activity and your
identity is anonymized by a secure vpn
server and your data is encrypted for
maximum production and my favorite thing
about expressvpn is how easy it is to
use i just fire up the app and click one
button and it's doing its job and
because it doesn't cause any lag or slow
anything down i barely notice it running
expressvpn works on phones laptops and
even routers so everyone who shares your
wi-fi can be protected secure your
online activity by visiting
expressvpn.com
rogue today that is e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
[Music]
dot com rogue and you can get an extra
three months for free
expressvpn.com
rogue but hey one of the best aspects of
the dark knight is the cool tech that he
brings into any situation which leads us
to our second topic of the day where the
hell does bruce wayne get all these
wonderful toys because this is the most
reclusive bruce wayne that we've ever
seen he apparently never goes into the
office and what's left of his
inheritance seems to be dwindling and
there's not even a mention of wayne
enterprises for god's sake so if in fact
this bruce wayne doesn't have his own
company to manufacture his gadgets where
are they even coming from where do you
guys think i think he's still making
them um
because it looked like he was
first off he had and i guess you can buy
equipment and be very knowledgeable and
proficient in it but he was more than
proficient he when he was giving um
zoe
kravitz all the gear he was just like
working on these little knobs and doing
everything so much printing and going in
zooming at first i was like oh maybe
alfred's making them and then alfred was
like what's this and i was like okay not
the question or not the answer not it
and then so i think he's still building
it and because the work room you see all
the tools still around he's like still
working together and putting things
together i think what is great about it
is instead of like buying a lot of the
pieces i think he's finding a lot of the
pieces because like his money is
dwindling like you said and i don't
think he really goes out period so he's
just like i'm making do with what i have
in this [ __ ] dungeon basement with
all these bats and i was like okay so i
think he's actually creating them and
we're getting
and we're just getting like a very very
very smart intelligent
prodigy batman
as he was as he was so like
because like in the dark knight series
or the christopher nolan's like we had
lucius fox make all of his gear so like
in this universe it's sort of like
lucious foxes in his brain my brain
[Music]
morgan freeman should be the voice in
everyone's brain to be honest oh my god
because he narrated the march of the
penguins
exactly
the water love this penguin
[Laughter]
but no um
sorry uh my brain just farted uh
yeah i really like this idea of of bruce
wayne just making all of his gadgets
because it just makes it easier so like
he doesn't have to like i don't know
because like in the dark knight trilogy
that guy was trying to extort bruce
wayne to be like hey i know that you're
a batman because i find out you're
expensive that you you're paying a lot
of weird stuff for your paid for tanks
and stuff i don't know what's going on
so like yeah it would it would be a lot
better if bruce wayne was just making
his own stuff that makes a lot of sense
here but what do you think what do you
guys think i think that it is incredibly
obvious that he got the nas tank from uh
you know vin diesel and ludacris and
tyrese gibson from the set of the fast
and the furious uh i i think that batman
is definitely friends with those guys
and i think that they hooked him up with
the nos they were like
yo the way that that car boosted uh yeah
it's got to be vin diesel it's got to be
it's like
when the penguin first saw it i thought
it was sputtering out of gas and i was
like oh god
it's like what an embarrassment
what an embarrassing story
i went oh he didn't what is it when you
like change gears but you're not doing
it well i was stalling i guess i don't
know
but yeah i thought he stalled his own
car and i was like wow you look stupid
that would be snl hilarity i would i
would love that [ __ ] a lot so i don't
know where he gets the other [ __ ] but
the gnaws definitely vin diesel
definitely definitely
yeah but i am i'm really excited
actually to see broke-ass batman because
that's a batman that i can personally
relate to a batman who is slowly running
out of money because he keeps buying
stuff that's me baby that's me on black
friday every year uh i think yeah i
think that he he got all the toys by
spending all of his money and that's why
he's broke like you know how like some
people call it like being house poor
when you have like a really nice house
but you're broke like that like he has
like a a vin diesel tesla but that's why
he's broke yeah that actually would make
a lot that would make sense and he's
just fixing the gear that he already
owned especially because like he seems
to have zero interest in being a
businessman right this is a batman that
is 100 there's no bruce wayne there's
only batman right like when he's not in
the cowl he's thinking about the cowl
right like so he's not maintaining a
billion dollar empire right he's only
interested in beating up street toughs
or whatever right it's so true because
like we see that at the at the beginning
of the movie where like he has no regard
for his own life like not even outside
of the social element he was just like i
don't really care what happens to me i'm
like i'm just going out beating up
people because i have this trauma so
like you know i think that him spending
all of his money on his gadgets because
he just didn't care about you know the
consequences of of you know spending all
this money just makes a lot of sense for
this batman you know it's like i i don't
care like money is no thing for me like
and honestly he had no idea of what
basic things were like when he picked up
the paint thing it's like oh yeah this
thing i mean not the paint thing when he
picked up the carpet
yeah that showed uh he was like what's
this like poor people stuff
he said on carpet
to be fair that was a chrome
carpet tucker that was a very fancy
carpet tucker i don't know carpet
installer that chrome okay
um that's the kind of carpet and tucker
you would use it at wayne manor is what
you would do oh in real time
a gold carpet tucker for the waves that
was that scene and the scene where
uh riddler was like breaking down like
well you think you're an orphan but
you're not an orphan like i'm an orphan
i was like yeah batman i i guess i
understand he's young and doesn't
recognize it yet but i was like do you
still not recognize your privilege are
you still stuck on the fact that your
parents are dead i mean i i get it
that's really sad but also what happens
to the kids that are
poor with dead parents there is there's
a lot of looking in the mirror for
batman in this and i loved it i need
that um all the time
everybody needs to check their group
every once in a while yeah i love the
idea of that
like a poser orphan
i have an old school rogue theory here
okay so okay this particular batman
universe as designed by matt reeves
right is like irredeemable everything is
corrupt right there's no uh white knight
that's gonna come in right this is
darker than dark knight right like uh
from the top down right like james
gordon and bruce wayne won't be the only
two good people in this city right
so i think what if he bought a lot of
his tech from the black market right
maybe stolen from government research
facilities stolen from foreign
governments right he buys it off the
board
yes right
but
by buying it from whoever the thieves
the black market operatives that stole
it right he is funding the same gangs
the same criminal element that then he
has to fight right again what blurring
that line between batman the vigilante
and the criminals that he's fighting
right they look alike
they operate and there's even a
financial cycle that is feeding them
right he's unaware of this that could be
a cool reveal for the second movie right
that like kind of um uh the the guy that
he paid you know 100 grand for the weird
batarang or whatever right is also the
supplying the drops to the kids of
gotham is also uh working for penguin
right like in batman unknowingly
is feeding the system he's trying to
fight
so you think that batman is being like
his dad falcone do you think he doesn't
recognize that the person he's buying
from is doing ultimately horrible things
absolutely right because because what
did we get in the in the denouement of
this film right like they unmask the
riddler goon and the guy doesn't say i'm
nobody or i'm the riddler or anything
like that he says i am vengeance right
batman is inspiring the people he's
fighting he inspired the riddler to do
what he did who then inspired all these
people right like batman is not the
solution to the problem batman is
causing the problem as much as anything
else right including with his talents of
the father bro i really love that i love
that i just don't think that he i still
think it's a great theory i'm like is he
stupid enough to be buying tech from
someone that's obviously doing bad he
didn't research the [ __ ] that he bought
this is these are theories he was dumb
enough to not know that a rat with wings
was a bat uh i know like i was like why
did you not go for that was that was a
writing description
obviously that was a writing that was a
writing snafu i was like this
justification is really bad i was like
how do you not know that he's talking
about your ass
exactly i was like
instantly but the one that's about you
you don't get why and i would and i'll
give the riddler his due those other
riddles were really hard i kept being
like what is this and then he was like
bribes and i was like i don't think
that's right and he was like correct and
i was like okay
but no the other ones weren't i like i
love zach's theory i was just asking
more of like i was like if it did happen
i guess he would have to be really young
and just be like i bought these guns
it's only a year or two for him
well he's he's willing to bend some
rules right he's willing to physically
beat up people you know as they commit
crimes right he's not a cop he is like
you know this kind of dark street level
avenger maybe you know he's willing to
bend the rule of like okay i'll deal
with a criminal element if it means i
can get cool attack and and i do agree
like he is a noodler himself right he we
saw the like the manifold of the
batmobile like off of the car right it's
under like a sheet he's clearly in there
he's a wrencher he's he's putting some
elbow grease into the gear but like i
don't think like the you know
uh black mirror-esque uh eyeball contact
lens uh recorder thing like he got that
from somebody right we didn't see we
didn't see a clean lab in uh wayne manor
where he could be making microchips
right i couldn't
get with like an ophthalmologist for
that right like he has like an
ophthalmology that's what i was gonna
say i could see him like busting
something big and then just keeping that
for himself after he busted like a
villain doing it he was like this is
something i need to keep so i can work
on it and keep for myself more than him
but i would like but i the zack theory i
like because it does shadow what his dad
did and it means like you're trying to
do good but you're doing a horrible way
of doing it uh which is batman's entire
career is just like putting justice in
his own hands where he does not need to
be doing
um so i do ultimately agree with
zach's name i change changes
no no no stick with your thing because i
like your thing too but i love that this
is like i love how deeply flawed this
batman is right like yeah maybe not
until the end of the movie when he's
just straight up saving people from
floods and like helping
you know medevac people off the roof of
the dome or whatever is he actually just
like directly helping people otherwise
he's driven by revenge right he's driven
by like kind of you know petty anger or
whatever uh he's not like a purely good
guy he is a dark knight right um yeah i
love that and so i think it'll be
whatever the answer that is it's going
to be complicated maybe he's taking a
tech that belongs to orphan children
right like that could be used
to feed the hungry eight-year-olds of
the city and instead he's building
batarangs and smoke bombs you know the
riddler actually made it and he was like
he said this is for me
[Music]
a rat helmet i don't mind if i don't
okay that is kind of also from the fast
and the furious though because there's a
part in fast and the furious where one
of the scenes is that they like tape a
rat to a guy's chest and then like burn
the outside so that their rat starts
burrowing into the dude's body and i was
like the riddler got that from vin
diesel
whitney is a huge fast and furious fan
and we all just found out today
i became one during the pandemic because
i had never seen the franchise and
i was like it's 20 20 i'm stuck inside
forever i'm gonna watch everything
as long as tokyo drift is your favorite
one i don't have a problem as long as
tokyo
[Music]
um
because luda has his song on it you know
and it's ah it's just a good one we
should just have a rogue thing anyway
getting back up track here yeah sorry
sorry off track
but no uh these are all again amazing
theories as always i love this idea of
course of you know bruce wayne spending
all of his money because he's just like
i just don't care and like i'm just
gonna spend all the wayne fortune on on
these gadgets of course so i'm gonna
give that theory
7 million uh rogue points waiting i'm on
the millions or the thousands i think
i'm a millions seven million rogue
points to that theory for sure and the
idea of bruce wayne creating all of his
gadgets makes a lot of sense as well
because like you know he's a super smart
dude and we don't have lucious fox in
this universe so you know if we're not
going to lucious route then it would
just make sense for bruce wayne to just
make everything in-house so i'm going to
give that theory seven million points as
well but zach's theory about bruce wayne
basically repeating the the sakes of his
father and gonna have to give that 10
million right there like that's so
that's a 10 million dollar idea um and
you know it seems like something matt
reeves would do because the whole sins
of the father thing so yeah i'm gonna
give you 10 million points for that but
now it is time for my favorite part of
the show is the rogue question you guys
ready yes so ready
because this batman film did not give us
one of the most iconic moments in any
batman movie the death of thomas and
martha wayne it i i honestly didn't feel
like i felt i watched a batman movie
because i didn't see them die like did i
even watch about i don't even know
what's going on there jesus matt reeves
we only seen them die a million times
just kidding i'm glad i didn't show that
so what is your rogues theory of how
this played out in this batman universe
like what do you what do you guys think
realistically i think it was done the
same way as it normally is because they
did say like she was they were killed by
like a when alfred was going off in his
bed he was like
they were like it was a thug it was a
random person that was down out on cash
and killed them or it could have been
falcone or it could have been so and so
i've been running these through my mind
all day so i do ultimately think it was
just still the same situation
of like
of
i guess but it sounded like batman
wasn't there with them right
through like everything that was said
what is your rogue theory like okay
that's like what's
let's
next
okay yeah and
okay i can go first i think
what actually happened was they went to
a nice dinner on the rooftop of wayne
manor and they were pushed off by the
waiter who was actually working for
falcone and they fell to their death and
no one could caught them or caught them
i know what if you thought you're gonna
go with kite man oh no wait no i think
man who you know is accident prone so he
survived but the other one splattered in
midair
god damn it yeah no i do i know i like
that of them just being on a rooftop and
then them just randomly dying that'd be
a fun little uh would you like some
water yeah and then like get pushed
fall
that's running for me says me the
commissioner pete
all right what do you guys think i want
to meet serial killer bruce wayne who
kills his own parents
[Music]
yeah
who killed my parents and it's like it
was you dude it was you
yeah
i love that too i'm i'm gonna go with
uh because again this gotham this batman
universe is like the most rotten right
like it's the most corrupt the most run
down so i think they were murdered by a
pothole right they're driving uh
they're driving the wayne maybach or
whatever right they hit a pothole that
is so gnarly it pops
one of the tires right a skirt right
they've got to pull over
that's when the gangster comes out and
caps both of them in the backseat of
their stretch maybach right so so though
it was a gangland style hit set up by
carmine falcone it was truly the
infrastructure and the lack of proper
road maintenance that killed the waynes
which is why we needed the mayor in the
first place
why we needed renewal for the first
place i
i really love that idea because like it
does tie it into the whole theme of the
movie of just like renewal and like how
the city needs to be fixed so like if a
pothole is was the agent of their demise
[Music]
why doesn't batman just go to like you
know one of those like meetings where
everybody in town goes to and just just
there's too many potholes they kill my
family
my family's dead because you guys didn't
feel any cracks in the road what if
bruce wayne doesn't believe him that's
like a super active next door account
and he's just like hey
this pothole needs to be fixed he
doesn't he doesn't believe he thinks a
representative democracy is a failure
you've got to take these things into
your own hands right yeah yeah he's like
wow now i need to go beat up every low
life in the city
everyone i deem unworthy i have to go
beat up now
you should be filling cracks in the
sidewalk those kill way more people than
than
not trying to be
rude but batman how about you put that
anger into making your community better
by cleaning up the garbage refilling all
the potholes you know community service
boom yeah hang out hang out with bella
real little trash on the side of the
highway it wouldn't kill you bruce
go work for the food bank go sort some
cans go door-to-door
give people yeah dude if aunt may worked
at a soup kitchen bruce wayne can get
his [ __ ] out
of lobbying like the rest of us because
at the funeral bruce wayne never just
tried to like vote
i do love it at
the
the
funeral
question
yeah does batman bruce wayne vote oh
right sir
he does not he does not he does not vote
he just goes getting kicks ass i love at
the funeral bella real calling him out
being like i noticed you haven't
participated in philanthropy
right like
she cornered him and held his arm and
was like so like your dad used to do a
lot of work but you don't do [ __ ]
and she's like let me go get my wishes
really quick but stay right here and i'm
gonna cost you some weight [ __ ] bruce um
but we'll continue this after this
tragic event yes
but no um i'm gonna have to give this to
zach
again is such a creative mind i love you
zach so zach is easily our winner for
today
zachary
coming in with a dub but that is it for
this episode of rogue theory
bottle with a gun
but that is it for this episode of rogue
theory thank you to our amazing special
guest jessica clements whitney van
leningen i'm of course off screen
producer zack support all their stuff
and what they're doing on twitter
wherever they are and support our
channel by checking out all of our
awesome merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com and hey if you've
got thoughts on some of our rogue
theories you can share them on our
discord so if you're over 18 just search
for new rockstars discord server and
just join the conversation because we
would love to have you i love all our
nerd babies you can follow me at
mastertain if you want to see me tweet
some weird [ __ ] but most importantly
just follow the new rockstars wherever
we are on social media and just be sure
to subscribe to our channel here on
youtube and hit that notification bell
so you get notifications every time we
upload a video but again thank you guys
so much for watching with us we love you
guys so much and we appreciate your time
we'll see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you